this video is for all my friends who are
doing you know one million three million
five million dollars a year
and who come to me and are always like
man
i want a challenge this is so boring i
want to do something new and exciting
and so let me tell you a story um about
my neighbor and so my neighbor had a
trash business
all right trash collection business
about as boring as it gets and he sold
his business a few years back for
a lot of money i'll just put it that way
and i was walking one day
and uh he was like watering his lawn and
i was like hey man
um you know what's going on and uh he
said i
just got out of my non-compete and i was
like oh that's awesome so you know what
are you planning on doing he's like
well i plan on doing the exact same
thing again and i was like wait what
what do you mean
he was like well i plan on starting
another trash business and selling it
right back to the guys who bought my
last one
and i was like what and like he could
tell that i was kind of like confused by
this and he was like
he's like why would i learn something
new he's like i already know everything
about the trash business he's like i'll
just do it again it just really hit me
because i was like
so many entrepreneurs myself included
right and i made this mistake so many
times earlier on in my career
we desire novelty we desire challenges
we want
growth right but the thing is is that we
think growth means new
when i think that a lot of times we
could redefine growth as meaning
we develop the character traits to be
able to persist and continue to do the
same things over and over again you
don't see these real estate moguls for
example being like man i've built
you know 20 million dollars in real
estate i kind of just need a challenge
i'm going to start i'm going to start a
restaurant
right they don't do that i mean think
about how stupid that would sound to you
you're like dude you're so good at real
estate just keep doing real estate right
but i see this especially in the
marketing community more than anything
is this this need for constant change
and
and and growth and challenge right but i
think you need to redefine the
challenges
this is becoming hard for you because
you're getting bored so the challenge is
learning
to a be comfortable with boredom or b
not need it
because the business doesn't exist to
satisfy
our internal deficiencies right that's
usually when most of us build it we're
insecure
we need connection we need we want
status right these are all the things
that we build our business to solve but
our business doesn't actually need to
solve any of those things it just needs
to provide value to the customer
and then we try and extrapolate or
project our own needs onto the business
and in so doing break our businesses and
make the wrong decision
and so let me tell you a different story
so i've had one two
three different guys tell me uh in the
in the internet marketing space who i
say one's doing 15 to 20 million another
is doing about 10 million now there's
doing about 10 million a year
probably in the neighborhood of like
three-ish million in profit per year
around there three to five and so each
of them
on their own reached out to me and said
hey man i think i'm gonna start um
a software company because i'm uh i'm
not i'm not challenged enough doing this
anymore
right and um i thought about that and i
just thought how
kind of hilarious it was it's like i've
risen to the top of my game
i'm bored doing what i'm doing and so
i'm going to stop doing this and then
i'm going to enter a new arena where
everyone else has been doing that for 10
years
and there are other kingpins in that
arena and i'm gonna try and relearn
everything from ground zero
uh and then try and beat them now here's
what's interesting
right here's what's crazy if you were to
let's say make a hundred thousand
dollars a year in your business and you
decide that you're going to be a true
entrepreneur and it means you're never
going to quit
and it means that you're going to
continue to do business for you know 40
years or whatever right
if you were to gain at the same pace as
the marketplace which by the way when
you're smaller is really easy right it's
10 a year
if you were to grow by 10 a year by the
end of the 40 years you would have a
gazillion dollars right
but most people are always trying to
beat the market when in reality if you
just
matched the market you would become
extraordinarily crazy wealthy
at the end of this game but because we
are so frenetic and we have these
insecurities that we project on our
business and then force our business
to solve our own personal issues we end
up breaking the thing that is actually
working just fine
because we have these interpersonal
needs that we're trying to satisfy and i
this was very hard for me to learn i'm
saying this because for me this was a
mistake that i made over and over again
probably for the first four years of
business for me i tried to make my
business solve my personal problems
when it really just needed to solve my
clients problems and i needed to do with
my own personal
stuff right one of the things that i
wanted to give you was the ways that i
create uh challenges for myself
within the business without destroying
the business all right so let me give
you two different things that have been
complete lifesavers for me
so i have desires for innovation i have
desires for new things
right and so where to channel that is
not to create new businesses
where to channel that is to create new
front ends or new backends so meaning
like
how can i change the hooks how can i
change the creative how can i change the
ad ideas the marketing the front ends
that bring people in because the more
variety i have there the more different
types of avatars i'm willing to attract
and ultimately grow the business so you
can use that entrepreneurial add but use
it in a way
that's going to serve you right and
serve the business without rather than
breaking the business right
whereas if you start creating more
businesses to satisfy your add then what
ends up happening is
well you know you have lots of
businesses and you don't have any money
that's the first thing the second thing
that i do
um that i'll walk you through is
understanding constraints all right
one of the the lessons that i've learned
over the last 12 months is
multiple metrics for success and so i'll
dive more into that in another video
but basically for a very long time in my
life the only metric for success that i
had was how much profit and how much
increase in net worth i had at the end
of the year that was it's all i cared
about
and i think that as we've gotten to the
point where like an increase in net
worth
the marginal utility of more money
meaning like the amount of extra
good that i can purchase or that more
money can purchase me is very very
little
right there's nothing that an extra 10
million dollars or an extra
50 million dollars is going to purchase
me that the first you know 50 doesn't
buy me right there's nothing right that
i can
there's nothing that i can't already get
right and so when you think about things
like that
right what it forces you to do is create
different ways to win right because it's
a game right if you're entrepreneurial
then you should
especially if you become more successful
you'll see it as a game right and so you
have this game that we're playing
and we have these metrics for success
that originally are just increasing net
worth right
but then you could say can i increase my
net worth and have a good marriage can i
increase my net worth and
and be in shape right and so one of the
constraints
that i'd like to offer you as a
challenge to give to yourself so that
you don't get bored
in the business that you have is a
constraint around time
right and so that was one of the things
that i did over the last 12 months was
like okay
i want to build something that does a
billion dollars a year in revenue which
is the goal for the portfolio and
transparently we're not
there you know we're at about 85 million
dollars a year across our portfolio
we're still a little short um but it's a
good thing to focus on
now the thing is is that i don't want to
make
and the way that i have to make that is
i can't i'm not gonna outwork to get to
a billion right
you have to make good decisions and you
have to let compounding work in your
favor
right because if we have the 85 million
and we go grow by 10 a year
in you know 20 years we'll probably be
there right
and so well let's see a doubling would
happen every seven years so 21 years
would be double double double so that
would be
two four eight so eight times 85
no we'd still be so we need another
doubling so we'd have to like 28 years
from now
we could be it if we just grow at the
market rate which is pretty encouraging
i think because i think we can beat the
market right
but anyways the point is adding
constraints makes the goals far more
interesting
because i think the first level of
achieving any goal is learning how to
sacrifice everything to achieve the goal
which i think
candidly i don't know many people who
are super successful who haven't done
that
you have to be able to put everything
you have on the altar of success and
sacrifice it for what you want
some people may not like that idea and
that's fine i don't i just don't know
people who are ultra successful who have
done that
and the reason they are willing to
sacrifice everything is because the
deficiency they have in their soul is so
great
that the pain they're suffering from is
like for not having the thing is so
great that they'll put everything else
on the altar for their success and i
know that i did that firsthand and so i
remember even when i
when i was growing growing into this
entrepreneurial role that i didn't tell
myself
um i'm gonna outwork everyone because i
didn't even think that was realistic i
said i will out sacrifice everyone so
when my competitors are going out to
dinner when my competitors are hanging
out with their kids or my competitors or
hanging out with their wives or being
good husbands i was like i will get
ahead
that was what i told myself and it
worked but at a certain point and this
is why multiple metrics of success are
important
the new goals that i'm setting have
constraints on them because anyone can
just sacrifice everything
to get what they want but the question
is can i
build a billion dollar a year revenue
portfolio working two or three days a
week
right and can i do that also while being
in
competitive shape physically right and
working out one to two hours a day
because i like it
can i do all of those things and so this
is kind of the new levels of challenge
i'm doing rather than trying to
break what i have and going doing 10
other new things
it's like can i add constraints to the
existing game to make the game more fun
for me
without breaking the machine because
ultimately like the machine doesn't
serve to
it doesn't exist to serve me uh it
exists to serve the customer and uh
making sure that i don't conflate those
two things
has been a very valuable lesson in the
very beginning for me i'll tell you the
story
when i when i started uh the first time
where i really
saw success was when i learned how to
sacrifice i was saying sacrifice earlier
so i'll tell you how i actually learned
how to do this so when i was in college
um
i ended up pledging a fraternity and it
was a very hard pledging process hard
being like time consuming right
and i think we had to basically every
hour of the day minus three hours
and minus class time so we had three
hours of study hall and we had
uh whatever our class time was all the
rest of the time we had during the day
we had to be at the house and doing
chores and stuff
and so that was pretty miserable and
that wasn't like you know a ton of fun
um
but what ended up happening was i ended
up getting really good grades that
semester
um in college and uh it was because they
forced me to do three hours a day
every single day of homework and if you
do three hours a day of work every day
and that's what i realized in college
um there's the days that you don't have
work to do if you still work three hours
you get ahead on future work
and so i realized that for only three
hours a day if i just did that i would
i think that that semester i got like a
383 or something like that what i did
after i finished pledging was i realized
that all these extra hours of the day
were mine and so what i did was i was
like well if i can just
study all the rest of the hours then i
should do really really well and that
ended up being a really good methodology
was i just sacrificed
all of my day um so i basically went to
the gym went to the library
um and went to class and that was it and
i i that was it i never worked past 9
p.m and i went out
almost the nights of the week but by
always doing it that way and not wasting
my time i ended up doing really well and
it was the first time i ever learned
how to sacrifice everything which was
everything else i just didn't do
anything besides work
work out and go to class like that was
it throw on day and so when i started
applying that same kind of concept to
business
it was actually fairly easy for me
because i was so used to sacrificing
everything i just
switched over what i was sacrificing for
and
i think that you have to learn how to
sacrifice first in order to learn how
not to sacrifice
later right because a lot of people were
like why would i achieve the success
you have or whatever but i don't want to
sacrifice x y and z i just
i think you can say that i just don't
know anyone who's done it um it's kind
of like saying i want to get over
the the hole that money has on my life
except i haven't made any money
i think you have to achieve something
before you can give it up
right i mean buddha who who gave up his
his worldly riches like he talks you
know he he walked the middle path
because he had been extremely wealthy in
a prince and then given it all up and
lived as a poor person and then walked
the middle path
and so i think that in order for us to
walk the middle path in life we have to
have achieved the thing in order
we have to achieve mastery over the
thing before we can truly master it and
mean and give it away
right and that's how we can eliminate
the desire for the thing because we
truly know what it's like to have it
right and then that means we can truly
know why we don't need it
and so i think that's um i know it
didn't mean to get 100 business
philosopher on you
um but uh but that's that's kind of
where i think this goes full circle so
um big picture here multiple metrics of
success
don't change your business just to
challenge yourself find new ways
to either create front ends or new
product lines or things like that within
your business that can satisfy your add
and if neither of those things are what
you want to do then
just use constraints to create
challenges in your own business that
improve your life in other ways
right and uh you can uh always go back
to my neighbor
uh the guy who sold his business for
trash uh his trash business
uh for a lot of money and uh and just
said he's like
why would i learn another business when
i'm already really good at this one he's
like i'd have to learn everything from
ground one he's like that just sounds
hard and stupid
and i couldn't really argue with the
wisdom of that advice because he doesn't
use his business to satisfy his
interpersonal desires he used his
business
to create wealth which was the whole
point so anyways i hope you found value
in this video
um click subscribe if you did more
videos like this uh to help you
make more money uh mozi nation keep
being awesome
and i'll catch you guys on flip side bye